et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Jean-Philippe Tanguy bonjour Merci
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Julien Lecuyer de la
Voix du Nord bonjour Julien bonjour
d'Emmanuel Macron hier soir pendant une
heure est-ce que ce matin vous y voyez
plus clair sur le cap fixé hier par le
Président de la République non mais je
pense que je suis nous sommes nombreux à
ne pas avoir pu voir plus clair ou le
président veut nous emmener veut surtout
emmener le pays j'ai trouvé que c'était
très bavard très long et très creux il y
avait très peu de mesures annoncées
aucun changement majeur on n'a pas
l'impression que vous savez quand il y a
une crise aussi grave que la crise de
l'inflation qui est durable
en fait il a pas changé sa politique
depuis sa réélection que fait-il depuis
sa réaction moi c'est quelque chose qui
revient très souvent dans ma circo dans
la Somme c'est mais où est passé
Emmanuel Macron il y a un sentiment
d'inertie de la part des Français de les
Français parce qu'il y a certainement
d'inertie à la tête de l'État ils ne
sais pas ce qui se passe ils ont
l'impression que la réaction de l'État
face à la crise sociale économique et
même sécuritaire et totalement absente
et d'autres elle est très affaiblie par
rapport
à la crise oui parce que vous savez la
crise de l'inflation remet tellement en
cause les grands éléments du macronisme
c'est-à-dire le libéralisme le commerce
international le fait qu'on ne doit pas
spécialement maîtriser des technologies
souveraines ou des ressources
souveraines ça a tellement mis à terre
toute cette idéologie qu'il faudra en
fait revoir de fond en comble la façon
dont Emmanuel Macron envisage l'économie
et la puissance française par exemple
hier j'ai vu qu'il avait annoncé
l'ouverture des mines de lithium donc le
lithium que la matière première qui sert
principalement pour les batailles par
exemple des années le rassemble national
et Marine Le Pen se sont fait insulter
mais quand je dis insulter c'est
littéralement insulté par les
macronistes et la gauche qu'on nous
proposons de rouvrir les mines
françaises ou d'ouvrir des mines
françaises
c'était anti-écolo c'était contre
non mais content alors moi je suis
content si ça se fait mais là ce sont
des mots et quand encore cet été j'ai
proposé donc pendant la loi de finance
rectif de modifier le code minier pour
commencer les recherches minières je me
suis on sait encore fait
toutes les ressources minières moi par
exemple dans ma circonscription entre
Doullens et Beauval j'ai une mine de
potasse c'est la potasse permet de faire
des engrais et vous savez à quel point
notamment dans la région des
Hauts-de-France la question de l'accès
aux engrais depuis la guerre en Ukraine
est très compliqué et bah c'est Manuel
Macron qui a fermé enfin qui n'a rien
fait pour ne pas fermer l'usine de
bazingal qui fabriquait des engrais et
vous savez que les d'ailleurs les
employés ont été abandonnés à leur sort
mais sur excusez-moi sur les mesures qui
ont été encore une fois annoncés par le
Président je pense à un mécanisme
d'amortissement pour les collectivités
et puis les petites et moyennes
entreprises un amortissement aussi pour
les particuliers un guichet pour les
grandes et les grandes entreprises ça ça
doit plutôt vous satisfaire mais si vous
voulez c'est pas dans la politique du
pire donc ce sont des petites mesures
qu'on prend comme elles sont mais déjà
ce sont des mesures ce sont des vrais
plus
et surtout on ne s'attaque enfin
Emmanuel Macron ne s'attaque jamais aux
causes de la crise par exemple hier une
fois de plus alors qu'il avait annoncé
que des mesures importantes seraient
prises au niveau européen qui sont à
l'origine de l'inflation des prix par
exemple le marché de l'électricité et
ben une fois encore Emmanuel Macron
n'est pas capable de dire aux Français
je vous protège je sors des règles
européennes stupides sur l'électricité
qui font que la France paye 5 à 6 fois
le prix qu'elle devrait payer grâce à
son énergie nucléaire hydroélectrique et
et en tant que président de la
République je protège avant tous les
Français non une fois de plus les
Français continueront à payer pour les
erreurs des Allemands c'est-à-dire oui
il y a des petites mesures des
amortissements des aides des petites
mesures et bien sûr
d'un ordre présidentiel d'ailleurs ce
sont des mesures qui existent déjà qui
sont prolongées qui sont un peu élargues
qui sont
des mesures qui nous place la France on
va dire dans le peloton de tête des pays
qui souffrent le moins de l'inflation à
l'heure
oui mais ça c'est ce que dit le
gouvernement
vous avez l'inflation enregistrée par
l'INSEE et vous avez après le niveau
d'impôts si l'inflation que vous ne
payez pas et payez par vos impôts et je
vous rappelle que cette année il y a le
record absolu de prélèvement obligatoire
plus de 40 ans
la sortie beaucoup de graphiques mais il
aurait plutôt dû sortir son bilan car il
est depuis 5 ans à la tête de l'État et
depuis presque 10 ans à la tête des
affaires économiques de la France en
tant que ministre de l'Économie et
avance sur cette intervenir les impôts
de 50 milliards oui bah alors je sais
pas comment on peut à la fois baisser
les impôts de 50 milliards est à la fois
avoir un record de prélèvement
obligatoire il y a quelque chose dans
les poissons d'Emmanuel Macron qui ne
fonctionne pas est-ce qu'ils voulaient
pas c'est la taxation indirecte c'est
notamment les TIC c'est la TICPE c'est
les hausses qu'il a faites de taxation
indirecte sur l'énergie oui mais vous
dites qu'il est parti très monsieur
l'aiguille vous avez raison sauf qu'il
est en l'air encore plus haut donc on
est parti de haut de plus bah oui parce
que si on a un record c'est qu'on a
encore monté bon donc on est parti de
haut c'était son bilan comme ministre de
l'Économie
on n'est pas des sens du sage je vais
vous le faites pas dire mais
effectivement lui il fait croire aux
gens et aux Français de bonne foi
d'ailleurs qu'il a baissé les impôts
parce que c'est pas revu la taxe
d'habitation mais la spécialité de
Macron ou d'ailleurs de Madame borne
c'est de reprendre du main d'une main au
classement moyenne et aux classes
populaires ce qu'ils ont donné aux
classes privilégiées parce que oui les
impôts ils ont baissés où sur les
grandes entreprises sur les grandes
fortunes
sur les retraites oui là aussi est-ce
que cette porte ouverte par le président
pour une réforme qui n'irait pas jusqu'à
65 mais qui pourrait rester à 64 ans si
les syndicats étaient ouverts à un
allongement de la durée de cotisation
c'est plutôt un panneau de bon sens
selon vous non mais ça fait pareil ça
fait maintenant trois ans qu'on a ce
pack 2 sur l'âge un coup il fait
proposition inacceptable donc 65 ans
après il revient un peu en arrière pour
que ce soit un peu moins inacceptable
mais la réalité d'ailleurs madame roule
a dit hier c'est qu'en fait lui-même est
en contradiction avec ses propres
engagements de campagne précédent et
depuis le monde a changé le monde a
changé depuis le monde n'a pas changé
spécialement pour le marché de l'emploi
parce qu'ils l'emploi français n'a pas
été bouleversé et s'il a été bouleversé
quand tu écoutes Emmanuel Macron c'est
plutôt dans le sens de plus d'emploi
donc s'il y a plus d'emplois et plus de
cotisations donc il y a moins besoin de
changer le système de retraite donc
c'est totalement absurde c'est la
réalité c'est qu'en fait le conseil de
suivi des retraites qui lui-même pointe
du doigt un déficit qu'il faut résoudre
là le conseil de suivi
aussi qu'en fait il y a une petite il y
a une période de difficultés qui est
d'ailleurs est moindre que c'est qui
était prévu et ensuite en fait la part
des retraites dans le PIB et plutôt
stable et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'à
la base la retraite oui elle est très
certainement la plus haut des pays de
peut-être mais ça c'est un choix de
société ce que les Français veulent
faire un autre choix de société je ne le
pense pas et on revient à la mesure de
l'âge le problème c'est que beaucoup de
Français ne peuvent pas travailler aussi
longtemps et en particulier dans notre
région des Hauts de France et dans la
dans le département de la Somme ou des
métiers ces métiers sont des métiers
souvent très durs des métiers physiques
et c'est pour ça que la réforme que
proposait Marine Le Pen il y aura des
des mesures sur la pénibilité
les mesures de pénibilité du
gouvernement Hollande quand il arrive au
courant
il est face ce qu'il a fait ou il
prétend effacer ce qu'il a fait avant
c'est comme les Shadoks il fait donc il
y a un moment
compromis sur cette réforme Marine Le
Pen a fait une proposition de réforme
qui me semble encore aujourd'hui la
meilleure c'est à dire que les droits à
la retraite doivent dépendre de l'âge à
laquelle vous avez commencé à travailler
donc les personnes qui ont commencé à
travailler avant 40 ans peuvent partir
entre avant 20 ans pardon peuvent partir
à 60 ans et à partir de 20 à 22 ans truc
60 et 62 ans et après dans la réforme de
Marine Le Pen c'est absolument respecter
absolument mais ça c'est la réforme
actuelle c'est le système
mais ça c'est déjà le système actuel si
vous faites pas vos annuités vous avez
une décote donc nous on ne change pas ce
système là ce qu'on dit c'est que ceux
qui sont partis tôt doivent partir plus
tôt et ça nous semble être le critère le
moins technocratique parce que c'est
quoi si la difficulté toujours de
rajouter des critères de pénibilité et
de compagnie c'est qu'en fait à la fin
on ne sait plus qui bénéficie de quoi
c'est illisible et donc la mesure le
fait de commencer tôt correspondre en
95% des cas à des métiers pénibles
est-ce que Monsieur Tanguy vous le parti
ou l'opposition du cynisme et du
désordre comme le dit le président de la
République non et comme l'a dit
Marine Le Pen hier soir au moins
j'invite et on invite le président à
relire la Constitution le Gouvernement a
le droit de faire appel aux 49-3 et les
oppositions ont le droit de s'unir pour
voter une motion de censure et une
motion de censure c'est pas une feuille
de route pour gouverner c'est un motif
de censure donc quand le rassemblement
national vote la motion de censure de la
nupesse c'est pas qu'on va donner le
pouvoir à la nipples contrairement à ce
qu'a dit LR et Emmanuel Macron pour
justifier leur alliance de circonstances
c'est juste que on n'est pas d'accord
avec le gouvernement et qu'on veut une
autre voix et nous on n'a pas peur de
regarder Le Pen elle a dit qu'elle a
voté parce qu'elle était en terme
acceptable oui c'est vrai que vous étiez
sur le fait bien qu'il y avait une
question de fond aussi bah c'est sûr que
si vous faites des provocations dans
votre texte c'est plus compliqué mais
nous ne soutenons pas un texte on
soutient une démarche qui est celle de
censurer le gouvernement pour faire quoi
alors
on vote pas on vote une démarche mais on
vote aussi un texte politique une
déclaration politique donc dans une
certaine manière vous avez soutenu une
déclaration politique de la nupes donc
vous êtes vous êtes soutien de LFI vous
êtes soutien des écolos non moi je pense
que là c'est vraiment un abus de
l'orgasme
comme son nom l'indique c'est on censure
le gouvernement parce que qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire non non je suis désolé là
dans ce cas-là c'est quand même un
problème démocratique si on part du fond
si on part du principe qu'une notion de
censure est un programme politique
pourquoi parce que ça veut dire qu'en
fait le gouvernement pourrait ne pas
respecter le le Parlement quel qu'il
soit et qu'en fait les oppositions ne
pourraient jamais censurer le
gouvernement et qu'en fait même si ce
gouvernement est minoritait il pourrait
censé se gouverner dans la motion de
censure c'est dire vous êtes minoritaire
et la politique que vous faites ne
correspond pas à la majorité sur le fait
que de en votant cette notion de censure
vous reconnaissez que vous avez mis dans
la barre l'embarras à la fois la gauche
mais aussi les républicains en les
renvoyant devant leur responsabilité à
ça tout à fait d'accord avec nous on a
renvoyé à la responsabilité les
républicains ça
n'est pas le bon terme parce qu'on n'est
pas là pour cibler un parti politique on
est là pour établir une situation
politique qu'est-ce qui permet au
gouvernement aujourd'hui de faire passer
les textes la rappelle tous les textes
on fait passer l'air ils ont fait passer
le projet de loi de finances
rectificative sur la promesse mensongère
du carburant en euro 50 que personne n'a
jamais vu ensuite ils ont fait passer le
texte sur le chômage maintenant c'est
grâce à eux que le budget passe parce
que la responsabilité de LR c'est quoi
c'est que si votre pas la motion de
censure pour des prétextes politiciens
le budget passe c'est-à-dire que les 150
milliards de déficit il passe le record
de prélèvement obligatoire de taxe
d'impôts il passe la disparition de la
protection des automobilistes au 1er
janvier l'absence de mesure sur le bois
le fioul au 1er janvier ça passe
l'absence de mesure sur les salaires ça
passe c'est ça les conséquences moi je
vois depuis deux jours on ne parle que
des conséquences politiciennes de la
motion censure mais quels sont les
conséquences pour la vie des Français
c'est
inutiles de dépenses inutiles racontent
n'importe quoi quand on a 150 milliards
de déficits quand on est incapable de
rétablir les finances publiques alors
que chaque année on se présente comme un
Mozart de la finance et comme les
parents
d'accord mais sauf que Monsieur la
taille il a dit l'inverse parce que dans
les dialogues de Bercy qu'on nous a
ouvert la France et le dernier pays à
revenir dans les critères de Maastricht
qui sont eux-mêmes posé d'ailleurs qui
sont des critères absurdes en 2017 en
2025 parce qu'il veut pas de brutalité
vous êtes d'accord avec ça alors vous
voulez de la brutalité c'est de la
fonction c'est de la bonne gestion des
finances je vais vous donner un exemple
concret c'est même pas nous tiens c'est
LR il faut un amendement pour proposer
que toutes les oppositions se réunissent
avec le gouvernement pour établir la
liste des dépenses technocratiques des
comités
inutiles de la bureaucratie et qu'on
fasse le ménage bon il devrait être
d'accord puisque les oppositions
veulent prendre leur responsabilité et
bah même ça ils ont refusé quels sont
les économistes structurelles de la
macronie rien du tout et c'est à dire
que qu'il faut s'attendre à ce que vous
déposiez de nouvelles motions de censure
s'il y a de nouveau 49-3 ah oui on ne
s'interdit rien c'est à dire quand on a
eu hier soir elle a déclenché à minuit
Elisabeth borne un nouveau 49-3 vous
avez jusqu'à ce soir d'une mention de
censure est-ce que vous allez le faire
bah écoutez on se réunit aujourd'hui
pour réfléchir au fait qu'on la dépose
ou pas on s'interdit pas du tout de la
déposer bien sûr non parce que nous on
veut pour revenir à votre question tu es
là Monsieur cuit on est aussi à partir
on veut avoir de la liberté d'action si
on a des automatismes comme la nupes
vous savez ce que vous faites ce que
vous êtes et vous réalisez comme Pavlov
le Sean Pavlov avec des automatismes
nous on veut avoir une liberté d'actions
du budget de la Sécurité sociale
pourquoi elle vous en déposeriez une
contre la totalité du budget de la
sécurité parce que ça faisait un tunnel
de motion c'est à dire qu'on nous avait
dit ce serait le même jour donc on
considérait que répéter la même chose
pendant 6 heures au Parlement était du
de l'obstruction pour le coup ça
n'apportait rien au débat public et
qu'on voulait pas rallonger les débats
pour rallonger les débats alors je vais
ouvrir des discussions importantes sur
la sécurité sociale là c'est l'inverse
là ce sera un nouveau jour donc là on
réfléchit ce matin on va se réunir pour
savoir si oui ou non dépose une motion
c'est quoi le critère si ça nous semble
politiquement opportun efficace
suffisamment rassembleur pour essayer de
rallier la nupes nous on fait toujours
des textes rassembleurs mais la
difficulté c'est que eux ils sont très
sectaires mais c'est une faiblesse pour
c'est une force pour nous nous sommes
pas sectaires notre électorat n'est pas
sectaire nos députés ne sont pas
sectaires et Marine Le Pen elle-même
n'est absolument pas sectaire ça a
provoqué quelques remous au sein de la
nuque le fait que vous décidiez de voter
leur notion de censure vous attendiez à
ça alors sincèrement non alors on
s'attendait à ce que les républicains
évidemment ne soient pas contents qu'on
démontre à tout le monde que c'était eux
qui fassent tenir le gouvernement mais
je dois dire que le réaction absolument
ridicule de de certains partis de laupes
bah moi ça m'a même les socialistes
il découvre qu'en fait pour s'opposer
Emmanuel Macron il faut voter ensemble
bon ils ont qu'à lire leurs amendements
parce que quand même pire Redbone député
socialiste faire un très bon amendement
pour ouvrir le crédit d'impôt pour
l'accueil n'est pas à tous les Français
qu'ils soient modeste ou privilégiés et
ben nous on le vote et si c'est
amendement il passe c'est parce que le
RN le vote donc les socialistes savent
très bien que quand il faut elle était
très contente que son amendement passe
donc à les socialistes savent très bien
que dans un dans la configuration pardon
du Parlement les amendements sont
bloqués ou passent si le RL le vote pas
parce qu'on est le premier parti
d'opposition donc c'est de l'hypocrisie
mais on est habitué à l'hypocrisie des
socialistes sur l'immigration Emmanuel
Macron a été interrogé hier sur les
obligations de quitter le territoire
français il a dit nous devons réformer
en profondeur nos lois pour pouvoir
mieux accueillir ce qu'on veut
accueillir cet accord avec cette phrase
non le problème c'est que surtout qu'on
devrait
réformer la pratique du gouvernement
pour expulser ce qu'on ne veut plus voir
son territoire la priorité c'est pas
d'accueillir du monde c'est d'expulser
les 700 à 800000 clandestins qui sont en
France et qui n'ont absolument rien à y
faire donc manuel Macron devrait se
pencher là dessus
puisque je vous rappelle que ça fait le
croire c'est la troisième fois que le
gouvernement Emmanuel Macron s'engage à
expulser 100% des
occitans on est à peine 10% voilà donc
il y a c'est une grande faillite une
grande faillite du gouvernement et quand
on voit le déplacement des mêmes Macron
en Algérie il y avait rien pour forcer
l'Algérie à reprendre ses ressortissants
alors c'est un des principaux pays
un bras de fer avec avec les pays les
pays d'origine le bras de fer il a déjà
eu lieu par le par le passé sont que ce
soit
efficaces
comment vous comptez réussir là où tout
le monde a échoué est-ce que le bras de
fer n'a jamais été mené en fait c'était
de la communication mais sur le fond
c'est les gouvernements d'ailleurs ils
sont assez cohérents puisqu'ils sont pro
et migration ils sont toujours été
polymigration et considère qu'on a
besoin de personnes immigrées pour faire
des travaux que soi-disant les Français
ne voudraient pas faire alors qu'il
suffit juste de les payer
il y a tout tout a toujours existé
depuis que l'homme est homme c'est pas
pour ça qu'il faut tout accepter voilà
ça ce n'est pas un raisonnement il y a
des choses qui sont acceptables des
choses qui sont pas acceptables si les
clandestins sont aussi acceptables que
l'immigration légale dans ce cas là on
fait plus de on fait pas de statut de
clandestins donc il faut les expulser je
rappelle que le le fait que des pays
acceptent le retour de leur clandestins
c'est le droit international c'est pas
une demande exorbitante de la France
c'est le droit international donc nous
on ira effectivement au bras de fer sur
la suspension des visas notamment des
élites qui ne sont bien contentes de
pouvoir se balader des élites de ces
pays mais aussi la suspension des flux
financiers de la diaspora bon et c'est
pareil pour l'Algérie c'est 7 à 8% des
revenus de l'Algérie c'est les revenus
financiers français de la diaspora donc
je pense pas que l'Algérie puisse se
permettre vous couper les vous coupez
les liens financiers vous faites comment
dire que les transferts d'argent seront
suspendus entre la France et l'Algérie
tant que l'Algérie ne reprendra pas ses
ressortissants et ces transferts d'agent
ils n'aiment pas que de que de
ressortissants sur le territoire en
situation irrégulière non mais c'est la
responsabilité mais vous allez faire
payer aux gens qui sont là la situation
régulière mais c'est à rien
en fait
finalement vous comptez sanctionner les
les personnes les Algériens qui ne sont
donc pas forcément d'ailleurs
responsables de la politique de le
gouvernement pas sanctionner ils vont en
France
ils ont de la chance de vivre en France
donc leur gouvernement est responsable
de leur situation vous savez dans ce cas
là on peut jamais rien faire on va pas
on ne va pas subir des situations
les flux financiers entre eux les
ressortissants algériens en France et
l'Algérie quand
vous avez remarqué que c'est très
efficace ça fait quand Emmanuel Macron
rappelle qu'il n'y a pas de lien
existentiel entre l'immigration et
délinquance vous le suivez au moins sur
le site sur cette phrase oui mais
personne ne l'a dit c'est-à-dire
personne n'a dit que par essence les
personnes immigrées étaient des
délinquants c'était une un lien qui
n'existe pas ça c'est un lien que font
nos adversaires politiques quand il
refuse de voir la réalité c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a il y a une sur-représentation
de l'immigration particulier de
l'immigration clandestine dans les faits
dans les délits et les crimes d'ailleurs
et Madame attend c'est reconnu pareil
c'est on en revient au début de nos
discussions encore jusqu'à la
présidentielle nous étions agonie
d'injures quand nous faisions le lien
entre statistiques entre la
sur-représentation de la délinquance
parmi l'immigration l'immigration
clandestine ce qui était la réalité donc
en fait c'est une grande victoire
idéologique pour le rassemblement
national mais c'est juste une victoire
de la réalité en fait un dernier mot
là-dessus sur la question des arts
médicaux peut-être Julien
celle de facilité l'emploi des médecins
retraités alors leur permettant de
cumuler
retraite et revenue sans cotisation
nouvelle ça vous semble une bonne piste
oui c'est une c'est une bonne idée
Marine Le Pen a toujours été favorable à
au cumul emploi retraite en particulier
sur les professions en tension après il
faut étudier ce qui est économiquement
le plus pertinent pour eux c'est-à-dire
qu'est-ce qui est plus intéressant
financièrement
est-ce que c'est la suspension des
cotisations retraite ou est-ce que c'est
un abattement fiscal supplémentaire ça
je pense que c'est au Parlement de le
voir moi j'ai pas la science incarnée je
ne sais pas ce qui serait le plus
efficace mais là je pense que ça
pourrait être l'objet d'un débat
parlementaire rapide et à priori plutôt
positif bien sûr
il nous reste un tout petit peu plus de
2 minutes sur d'autres sujets hier le
Parlement valider la nomination de
lucrémont qui sera donc le nouveau
patron de def vous avez réagi vivement
vous en parlant de trahison c'est pas
rien c'est une inclusion
pour les républicains de LR du scène
apparemment ici c'est à dire parce que
le LUC Raymond j'arrive même pas à
croire que c'est possible en fait
lucrémont était le représentant de la
Banque of America merylins quand cette
banque était le Conseil d'Alstom pour le
démantèlement d'Alstom et le pillage
d'Alstom pour les Américains donc nous
avons confié EDF c'est à dire la
souveraineté énergétique française à un
individu qui a déjà travaillé pour des
intérêts hostiles étrangers le
démantèlement d'Alstom qui vous rappelle
à détruit 5000 emplois France et
organiser le transfert des brevets
stratégiques des turbines nucléaires
arabels des turbines hydroélectriques et
des turbines gazir vers les États-Unis
et d'ailleurs c'est tellement un fiasco
aujourd'hui Monsieur Raymond
malheureusement confirmé à cause des LR
au Sénat va organiser le retour des
Arabel qu'il a lui-même vendu aux
Américains dans le giron d'EDF puisque
Dave les racheter en faillite donc c'est
le système de l'oligarchie parisienne là
on est dans une caricature je vous dis
au début je pensais que Monsieur Raymond
était un profil tellement inacceptable
que c'était une diversion pour qu'on
accepte un profil moins inacceptable
donc j'avoue je suis sidéré par ce qui
s'est passé hier et j'ai d'ailleurs je
vais me manquer rire personnellement de
ce qui s'est passé au Sénat parce que
visiblement d'après Marianne monsieur
Stéphanie qui est l'ami de Monsieur
Jérôme Pécresse qui était l'agent
d'intégration des activités d'Alstom
c'est le général électrique a fait le
tour de certains sénateurs LR donc
j'aimerais bien savoir là ça va loin
mais
quand vous dites vous enquérir ça veut
dire quoi et ben je vais savoir pour
quoi Monsieur
de saisir des autorités capables
d'enquêter qu'est-ce qu'a fait monsieur
Stéphanie au Sénat hier avant-hier
mais vous allez laisser dire quelles
autorités
du Sénat je vais essayer de savoir ce
qui s'est passé parce que le fait que
Marianne c'est pas moi qui l'invente
madame c'est ecrimo pour mot dans
Marianne hier matin le fait que Monsieur
Stéphanie avec Monsieur Raymond est
rencontré des sénateurs en marge de la
mission qui devait savoir s'il était
validé ou pas et quelque chose de très
grave et moi j'en ai assez que dans
notre pays il y a des pratiques comme ça
illégar chlic oligarchique qui offrait
une toutes les règles de déontologie ce
serait inacceptable dans toutes les
démocraties notamment scandinave
petite question sur la présidence du
rassemblement national qui aura le nom
l'élection aura lieu le 5 novembre de
mémoire
déjà d'une est-ce que vous soutiendrez
un des deux candidats Louis a lieu le
début Jordan Bardella pour la présidence
qui était un très bon président par
intérim pendant la présidentielle qui a
fait ses preuves et je pense que c'est
le meilleur candidat possible même si
j'ai beaucoup d'amitié pour lui et
dernière petite question mais c'est vrai
que Louis Aliot a fustig
bonjour Julien le BAFA plutôt plus vite
c'est à la Une de votre journal merci
Julien la semaine prochaine
[Musique]